this notion of feminism is supposed to
be about equality and equalism
um but when women have the right to do
something by going to get sperm it's
okay but I think when you're going to
find guys doing things like using
artificial wombs or even surrogates
there's loads and loads and stacks of
paperwork and there's ultimately going
to be government involvement especially
for artificial wombs if that's the thing
that becomes a reality in the future but
back to the point of the passport growth
thing sort of sort of building on the
idea of that of that video that I
published that's why women hate it you
know it's as simple as that
hot dudes that they want to be with
leave and find more feminine more
agreeable women in another country they
get mad about it so the second part to
this is how do how do guys screw this up
and they and they really do screw it up
a lot
um let me share something here which is
more or less like an expectation of what
um guys typically want or what they
think they're going to get so this is
something that popped up on my uh feed
on Twitter today
and I thought it was relevant so
um you know just kind of Place held it
but essentially I don't know this PD guy
is but he said no twerking no nudity no
makeup three girls singing a folk song
from what I don't know where throw in a
donkey and you're winning I find these
women attractive am I the only one now
it turns out I'm just going to play this
um I'm not going to run the audio
because it turns out these three girls
are very popular they have a massive
YouTube channel with over a million Subs
there's going to be copyright issues or
you know music uh I can't remember what
they're calling it but there's musical
infringements let's just call it
um but they sound sweet they're very
pretty uh almost no makeup on uh they
got a donkey in the background and
they're dressed in traditional clothing
like this is the this is the lie I think
and I'm gonna call it a live right now
but this is the lie that guys uh sign up
for when they go down the passport bro
uh road because this seems very
attractive you know super feminine women
I don't see any rainbows I don't see any
purple hair dye face piercings exposed
tattoos loads of skin uh they certainly
don't maneuver and act you know
promiscuous like this guy said over here
there's no twerking none of that stuff
they're just walking along singing a uh
relatively you know Pleasant song
enjoying themselves you know like
they're not tens but they're but they're
very attractive you know by Western
standards you know especially in North
America which is what most guys are
dealing with I mean somebody posted this
the other day on um Twitter but I think
the average weight of a North American
woman now is something like 170 pounds
uh plus
um so it's right up there right so this
is what's what's been sold right you
know you know pack your bag get your
passport go out here and win and go and
get you know a girl like this and
everybody's got their preferences you
know some some guys prefer uh Latin
women some guys prefer Asian women uh
but there's preferences that everybody
expressed but that's but that's
generally where it ends up going so
that's the I'm gonna call it a lie right
now I'm gonna explain why if you bear
with me on this
so back to that video with the whole
passport bro status so I noticed a few
of the comments and I sort of bookmarked
a few of them and there was one guy that
was I mean
he wasn't being disrespectful or rude
but he was pushing back a little bit and
he was talking about
um you know passport Bros and why it's
important and my understanding as I was
reading it was that he might have been a
password bro and had some experience to
share so I replied back to him I said
you know I clarified the
misunderstanding and I said look you
know if you've got experience in this
area I'd love to have you on a podcast
and you can talk about it and uh I said
you know just email me so he emailed me
and
my misunderstanding was not incorrect
um he went on to talk about his business
a little bit which is cool and you're
like my book awesome thank you
um but he said regarding my passport bro
status I must confess I haven't traveled
outside of the U.S yet however I do have
a passport and I'm currently in a
relationship with a woman from the
Philippines never anticipated being in a
long distance relationship but she's in
my frame and she aligns with my values
she never asked for money she doesn't
have any children she is responsible has
a good job and she's actively actually
coming here to see me on the other hand
my dating life here at home I'm still
considered average at least on paper so
of course I'm constantly working on
improve myself because I'm well aware
that even average women are not
attracted to the average man and when it
comes to attractive women average men
are practically invisible
he goes on to say therefore it's
refreshing to have someone who I'm
genuinely attracted to while striving
for excellence recently so he just talks
about First Property quit drinking quit
smoking weed and a few other
improvements to life which is cool
um so
this guy in the comments was holding out
or I was under the impression that he
had experience and it was the better way
to go and was kind of pushing back
because I made a comment in that video
about the passport bro movement
and I'm not a big fan of it just because
of the way that guys handle it and how
they screw it up and I'll explain that
in a sec this is kind of a
typical example of what I'll see right I
I'm in a long distance relationship with
a woman from the Philippines that I've
never met who's in my frame
so you haven't met her how is she in
your frame how do you know what she's
about how do you know if she's loyal to
you how are you in a long distance
relationship like I've talked about
long-distance relationships many times
on my channel and other podcasts with
people calling and ask about it and it's
not a relationship you are not in a
relationship if there is an absence of
intimacy you might be friends you might
be pen pals you might have expressed
interest but you're not in a
relationship now the truth of the matter
is is that the attraction for women
uh in some of these countries like you
know within Asia like Philippines would
be a good example Eastern Europe like
those three gals that were playing the
little banjo thing or the bazooki or
whatever might have been there in
Georgia or if it's Latin women you know
the Colombians or Mexicans or whatever
it happens to be
um
they're they're they're still genuinely
interested in the best man that they can
get their hypergamous nature Still
Remains the Same women are still women
women in the United States are really
not that much different from the women
in the Philippines Georgia or Colombia
they still want the best guy that they
can absolutely get and comparably
speaking you being in the United States
for example talking to a gal from the
Philippines you probably look like a
better Prospect to her than what's
available in her immediate dating
Marketplace I think this guy mentioned
in early earlier paragraph that what he
does is he uses an app like Tinder and
then switches his geolocation to one of
these countries and starts swiping and
matching but
you can't be in a long distance you
can't be in a relationship if you're
long distance there's a lack of intimacy
intimacy doesn't exist it's not a
relationship okay
um so
you know what do I keep telling you guys
men love to complicate their lives and
justify why they do it I'm in a
relationship with a gal that I've never
met who's purportedly in my frame it's
not a relationship you you have
expressed interest in a girl and she's
talking to you so she has an interest in
you but there's an underlying notion
that coming to a first world country
like the United States that's the dream
of everybody outside of the West they
want to come to a Western Country to
better themselves
um
Arnold Schwarzenegger is an amazing
example of that there's a documentary on
Netflix right now this sort of breakdown
you know breaks down his life and it's
like the passion and the the amount of
work and desire that had to go in for
him to leave Austria that little village
to end up you know where he did in the
states and marry a Kennedy and become a
governor and one of the highest paid
actors you know in the world that drive
in men is immense for women it's a
little bit different because they know
that their sexuality is their main
bargaining position right their beauty
their youth and their Beauties their
main bargaining position and being in a
country where
um women can still be objectively
beautiful
but the men don't really bring nearly as
much of the table as a guy even an
average guy in the states like this
guy's saying that he's just an average
guy in the states so so she's
purportedly choosing him and actively
wanting to come over and see him
great
um my advice in you know scenarios like
this where guys are contemplating the
passport bro move is go there and stay
there
uh would be the first thing do not bring
them back to the West because they will
be westernized within a couple years and
um
they're gonna turn to I'm just
telling you you know like it is they're
going to adopt Western values they're
going to start consuming the Kool-Aid
they're going to see all the media
they're going to see all the social
media all the new stuff the rainbows the
wokeness it's all going to get crammed
down their throats some of them will
probably protest and resist a little bit
more than others
um
but it exists and you know whether it's
one two three or five years they will
become westernized
um Eddie Murphy did a uh a Stan two
major stand-ups uh delirious and uh raw
I can't remember which one it was in I
think it might have been in raw but he
made this joke about unfufu which is
some African
zebra gal that and I'm using Kinder
friendlier language because Eddie has a
way with words but I encourage you to go
to YouTube after this and search for
Eddie Murphy unfufu and this is back in
the 80s and it's the same story back
then as what it is today right we're
talking like 40 50 years later right uh
not 50 years later but several decades
later obviously
it's still the same Dynamic you know you
think that you can go to a country and
bring one of these girls back and
they're going to remain feminine and
they're going to remain in their like in
their place but what ends up happening
is pretty much exactly what happened to
that guy that married the Chinese girl
in the video that I published on my
YouTube channel a lot of these guys find
these women are disagreeable they find
that they hoard the money they want to
control the money the house is never big
enough the car is never nice enough
um they withhold sex they use sex to
manipulate in the relationship
um they send a lot of money back home
and culturally you know that exists in a
lot of cultures right like um I know a
lot of Asian cultures especially you
know in the Philippines they will make
money here and the biggest export from
North America into the Philippines is
just cash it's just Western Unions
generally speaking I don't know if they
use crypto now but it's it's a movement
of money from North America back back
home to take care of their family
and that's something that like
bugs me you know to some degree when
when when people come to a Western
Country and they still use that language
back home right like
home is where you are at right now like
you wanted to leave back home because it
was a to come over here but
it's still back home like they still
call it home so money still transfers
back over that way I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full-length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out